first of all I want to know how excited
were you you got to wear a onesie in a
spacesuit you didn't have to show your
abs you didn't have to be shirtless did
you let your gut hang out through the
whole thing would you do would you think
I let my gosh I don't think you have one
but I would unzip and go here one of the
actors looks at you and says you look
older than I thought I know I don't
never say that to you I know wrong yeah
can we edit that out yeah I know I was a
little upset bananas's get over yourself
it's funny this is mr. J closer Z J
Clawson you look much older than it
would have fallen I mean good tell me
your favorite season and I'll tell you
what traits you want you tell me okay
are you a planner no do you get the job
done yes are you an organizer no I'm not
an organizer though yeah well I actually
um it's a toss-up for me big between
summer and spring because I love them
both equally I'll go through the trace
for spring and summer and you guys can
just tell me yes or no witty are you
witty yes tender-hearted yes yes
optimistic yes yes curious yes that was
spring summer gentle autumn interesting
planner mm-hmm gets the job done
true confident true here's your negative
traits easily irritated yes really
expression oh my god I'm good oh my god
both thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]